a Chinese delegation will go to
Indianapolis this week to claim a
massive trove of artifacts brought to
the US by an eccentric Indiana collector
the FBI seized about 360 ancient items
from ceramics to weapons in 2014 in a
story you'll see only on CBS this
morning Anna Werner reveals what else
the government found she's been working
on this story for months and a good
morning good morning and these artifacts
were part of a vast collection gathered
by a man named Don Miller he was 91
years old when the FBI showed up at his
home in 2014 for what may be the largest
seizure from a private collection
ever they said Miller wasn't supposed to
have many of those rare and ancient
items now we're learning some unsettling
information about what else the FBI
found when the FBI showed up at don
miller's home in rural Indiana in 2014
it was a shock for people who knew him
he was very beloved he was very
charismatic former local reporter Liz
dykes interviewed the 91 year old former
engineer about his time in World War two
his missionary work in Haiti and most of
all his huge collection of artifacts
from around the world the entire house
is a museum there are things everywhere
it was just mind-blowing
Miller even gave tours of his collection
so when the FBI came calling she says I
wanted to know what they were looking
for there had to have been something
there was something the FBI hasn't
talked about until now when I first went
into his house and saw the size of the
collection it was unlike anything we had
ever seen Tim carpenter heads the FBI's
Art Crime Unit unlike anything you'd
ever seen not only me but I don't think
anyone even on the Art Crime Team FBI
photos never before shown publicly give
a glimpse of the collection some 42,000
items including pre-columbian pottery an
Italian mosaic and items from China some
that Miller labeled Chinese jewelry from
500 BC roughly half of the collection
was Native American and the other half
of the collection was from every
corner of the globe this piece as you
can see it was labeled by mr. Miller
the problem carpenter says was that the
FBI found a lot of it had been illegally
obtained Miller admitted he'd gone on
digging expeditions in foreign countries
and around the United States for decades
in violation of Antiquities laws did he
understand that he had obtained some
things illegally he did so he admitted
that he did
Miller eventually agreed to let the FBI
seized some 5000 artifacts so they could
be returned to their countries of origin
but carpenter says all the FBI's careful
planning couldn't prepare them for
another more disturbing discovery about
2,000 human bones mm to the best of our
knowledge right now those 2,000 bones
represent about 500 human beings those
human remains he says were also dug up
nearly all of them from ancient Native
American burial sites okay that sounds
like a staggering number
it's very staggering why would anybody
have that many human bones I don't know
I truly don't know Native American
burial sites dating back thousands of
years have been a source of fascination
for archeologists for decades meticulous
care must be exercised this old
government film showed the excavation of
an ancient Native American village in
Alabama over time many other sites have
been looted by people seeking artifacts
and even skeletons this comes down to a
basic human right
Holly Cusack McVeigh is a professor of
anthropology brought in by the FBI on
the Miller case we have to think about
the context of who has been the target
of grave robbing for centuries whose
ancestors have been collected for hobby
and this comes down to racism they
aren't digging white graves experts
determine the remains found at Miller's
residence likely came from Native
American tribes including the Arikara in
North Dakota tribal official P
Coffee is working with the FBI to bring
them home all too often here we have
been treated as curiosities rather than
a people here it could very well be my
own great-great-great-great grandfather
or grandmother you know that had been I
characterized it as being ripped out of
the earth
you know Miller died in 2015 we wanted
to know what his widow thought about all
of this mrs. Miller so we went to
Miller's home where a Chinese terracotta
warrior figure stood guard outside but
carpenter believes in his later years
Miller understood the ramifications of
what he did I think he felt compelled to
try to do the right thing and return
these home returning those Native
American ancestors home which is what
carpenter says is the FBI's most
important mission now you have to treat
these people with dignity these are
human beings and people that matters it
has meaning to people today it has
meaning to our children and their
children well so far the FBI has already
returned items from Miller's collection
to several countries including Cambodia
Canada Colombia and Mexico
they've already returned some Native
American ancestral remains to tribes in
the South Dakota region and are planning
a large-scale repatriation of remains to
other tribes in the coming months it's a
big projects going to go on for years
a very unusual story yeah I'm still
thinking about that life-sized statue
right outside the home when you meet
Erica you know the Terra Cotta you ever
seen the terracotta soldiers in China no
never I have they're pretty impressive
thank you Anna